[Music]  Charlie Sheen's got a new lady this is  my girlfriend hey how you doing that's  module hey Julien I use no one's got the  front of us awesome we hear Charlie and  Jules have actually been dating since  late last year but like Charlie said  they were just photographed for the  first time together on Thursday that's  when they stepped out at Italian eatery  Giorgio Baldi in Santa Monica California  what's the occasion in celebration class  my daughter's birthday  Oh excellent man well the really good  age  Charlie's ex Denise Richards share this  sweet snap of the birthday girl their  daughter Lola at the dinner and  captioned it I love you so much  [Music]  you